Samsung va sortir sa toute nouvelle
expérience logicielle qui s'appelle
oneui 6 on va donc regarder quelles sont
les nouveautés comment ça fonctionne
est-ce qu'on peut venir en faire alors
regardez à gauche je vous ai mis un
smartphone de Samsung c'est le Galaxy
S23 ultra dans lequel je suis sur la
vieille version logiciel regardez c'est
écrit ici je suis sur oneehui 5.1 tandis
que sur mon zflip 5 je suis sur oneui
6.0 Samsung a fait un super boulot sur
son expérience logiciel avec plein de
nouveautés extrêmement pertinentes vous
êtes prêt à aller on y va la première
nouveauté elle arrive au niveau du
panneau d'affichage sur Onei 5 pour
arriver à votre panneau d'affichage
rapide vous descendez une première fois
une deuxième fois il y a une nouveauté
qui est arrivée sur oneui 6 si bien que
lorsque vous venez vous descendez et que
vous redescendez une nouvelle fois et
bien on voit que l'affichage est
totalement différent et ça c'est quand
même super bien la différence par
rapport à oneui 5 est très claire le
WiFi et Bluetooth sont mis en avant
qu'on vient retrouver sur la partie du
haut dans la partie centrale vous AZ
retrouver vos différents paramètres P
venir Swiper ici les activer désactiver
très facilement tandis que la partie du
bas donne la Parbelle au confort visuel
également en mode sombre qu'on peut
venir activer et désactiver ici et
surtout à la luminosité c'est très
facile très pratique c'est quand on
prend one 5 là tout de suite c'est un
peu moins ça vous pouvez venir les
modifier ensuite très facilement en
appuyant sur le petit crayon ici alors
là vous avez le choix soit vous modifier
ce qui est en haut ça vous modifier
complet en haut vous allez pouvoir venir
modifier les six icônes que vous allez
retrouver le bluetooth le Wii vous allez
pouvoir les déplacer très facilement et
ensuite on rajouter d'autres que vous
avez dans une liste tout en sachant
qu'ici vous pouvez en mettre uniquement
6 en haut si et pas de plus sur la
partie centrale on peut en mettre un
petit peu plus par contre vous
choisissez de la même manière dans une
liste avec toutes les touches qui vont
être disponibles ici et vous venez
ensuite les déplacer les repositionner
très facilement à votre guise c'est à
vous de voir autre possibilité vous
allez pouvoir retrouver soit directement
vos notifications ici d'ailleurs les
notifications on en parle dans quelques
instants ou alors accéder directement au
panneau d'affichage rapide par défaut
c'est pas possible ce qu'il faut faire
c'est venir dans vos paramètres vous
cliquez une fois de plus sur le petit
crayon ici et vous allez sur accès
instantané au raccourci vous venez
activer la fonction mais si vous passez
uniquement sur la partie de droite comme
ça vous avez accès directement à tous
vos raccourcis ça c'est extrêmement
pratique je vous parlais des
notifications il y a quelques instants
Samsung a fait une petite modif qui est
quand même vachement intéressante au
lieu de les classer par priorité on va
pouvoir venir les classer par heure
comme ça vous aurez accès ACC aux
dernières notification directement sur
votre smartphone et je trouve ça quand
même beaucoup plus pratique pour ce
faire vous allez dans vos paramètres
vous venez rechercher notification et
vous avez un nouveau menu qui vient de
faire son apparition qui s'appelle trier
les notifications là vous les TRIZ soit
selon la priorité soit par heure je
préfère quand même par heure on voit la
différence par rapport àui 5 vous avez
les notifications de l'application vous
avez une notification sur l'écran de
verrouillage mais cette partie trier les
notifications n'existait absolument pas
Samsung également venir faire une petite
modification au niveau de l'affichage
lorsque vous écoutez de la musique
lorsque vous allez dans le panneau
d'affichage rapide bien vous allez avoir
un affichage au niveau de la musique qui
va être mieux que ce qu'on avaitu 5
puisque la pochette de l'album prend
toute la partie de l'affichage ici c'est
beaucoup plus jolie vous voyez comparé à
oneui 5 c'est globalement pas tout à
fait la même chose il y a aussi quelques
petites modifications intéressantes par
rapport à l'écran de verrouillage et
notamment par rapport à l'horloge je
vous montre lorsque vous voulez venir
modifier votre écran de verrouillage et
notamment votre horloge et bien vous
avez de nouvelles possibilités vous
cliquez sur l'horloge déjà le premier
truc qui est cool c'est que vous avez un
nouveau style d'horloge ici c'est quand
même plutôt sympa audà de pouvoir venir
la redimensionner la mettre comme on
veut on peut la déplacer à droite à
gauche en en haut et en bas on a
beaucoup plus de choix que ce qu'on
avait avant sur oneui 5 avant on pouvait
uniquement l'agrandir le rétrécir mais
déplacer voyez c'était strictement
impossible et je vous le disais vous
avez un nouvel affichage qui vient
d'apparaître ici ça c'est quand même pas
mal mais Samsung a rajouté en plus
plusieurs polices d'écriture qui sont
quand même plutôt pas mal vous en aviez
six avant vous avez effectivement
toujours les C mê mais il y en a deux
nouvelles qui viennent de faire leur
apparition à vous de faire vos choix
d'ailleurs dites-moi laquelle vous plaît
le plus en commentaire mais les
nouveautés ne s'arrêtent pas là puisque
Samsung s'est dit des fois on a des noms
au niveau de nos applications qui sont
un peu trop longues et des fois ces noms
sont sur plusieurs lignes ce qui est pas
terrible on va notamment avoir le nom du
Galaxy Store qui est un peu long et
encore c'est pas le pire on va surtout
avoir Samsung TV plus c'est pas ouf
également Galaxy wariable sur oneu i6
ils sont venus corriger ça en supprimant
les galaxies en raccourcissant les noms
des applications Galaxy weable devient
weable Samsung TV plus devient TV tout
de suite beaucoup plus clair le Galaxy
store devient juste store bref c'est
plus simple plus visisible et ça on aime
autre nouveauté qui est pas mal on peut
venir faire des glissés déposés avec les
deux mains typiquement vous venez
choisir une application Marshall par
exemple ici et bien si je veux l'emmener
ailleurs et bien regardez je prends mon
notre doigt je déplace je l'emmène
ailleurs je viens la POS positionner où
je veux c'est simple c'est pratique
alors ça peut paraître très bête comme
ça mais sur oneui 5 c'était absolument
pas possible vous prenez une application
vous voulez la déplacer et bien on peut
pas il faut venir glisser votre Doig sur
le côté c'est quand même vachement moins
pratique moins intuitif je préfère
réellement ici ce qui est venu faire
Samsung avec oneu i6 autre nouveauté pas
des moindres du point de vue de la
sécurité Samsung a ajouté une option de
sécurité qui est vraiment intéressante
vous venez dans sécurité et
confidentialité et vous descendez vous
allez dans blour automatique vous voyez
avant ça n'existait pas ici première
chose on vient l'activer bien évidemment
et ça ça fera quoi regarde regez c'est
écrit ici ça bloque les applications
provenant de sources non autorisées donc
si ça sort pas du Galaxy Store ou du
Play Store on n veut pas ça va activer
le contrôle de sécurité des applications
ça va surtout bloquer les commandes par
un câble USB si vous utilisez un câble
USB que vous ne connaissez pas dans un
uber dans un hôtel qui n'est pas à vous
et bien tout ce qui va être commande par
la partie data ne passera pas vous avez
également les options avancées
protection avancée de la messagerie et
blocage des mises à jour logiciel par
câble USB une fois de plus tous les
câble USB qu'on ne connaî pas et bien ça
vient quand même sauver un peu
l'histoire alors attention si vous
voulez faire une mise à jour en
utilisant un câble USB vous vous
décocheer ça sinon ça marchera pas mais
Samsung est venu apporter également
plein de nouveautés sur la partie photo
vidéo au travers de leur application
regardez dans l'application Appareil
photo il a surtout une simplification
ici au niveau des icônes notamment au
niveau des live photos c'est plus
compréhensible ce qu'on appellera le
photo avec mouvement la partie filtre
aussi est beaucoup plus évidente mais
surtout l'affichage ici est quand même
vachement simplifié vous voyez avant c
un peu plus ostère pour venir comprendre
alors attendez ça c'est ça ok je
comprends mais c'est pas très évident
les filtres c'est où c'est ça les
filtres l'icône est pas la même CIT
beaucoup moins sexy et encore là je vous
le montre sur un zflip 5 qui fait que
vous avez une icône supplémentaire ici
pour activer l'écran extérieur est situé
juste là mais si vous le faites sur un
S23 ultra et bien vous aurez en plus le
nombre de mégapixels qui va venir
s'afficher et ça c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal et très intuitif autre nouveauté
pas des moindes c'est le scannerur
automatique à mainlever par exemple ici
je vais prendre un petit document je
vais prendre mon appareil photo pour
venir le scanner je prends mon doc il y
a mon doigt là il va venir reconnaître
le document mais je fais juste
enregistrer tout simplement lui ensuite
il vient reconnaître mon document et il
l'a scané proprement et surtout il a
viré mon doigt qui avait là il vient
reconstituer l'image et pour un scan
c'est quand même vachement bien alors
petite astuce de vous à moi ne posez pas
votre doigt là où il y a du texte sans
quoi ça marcherait pas et vous le mettez
sur une partie blanche ça vient le
supprimer et ça une fois de plus c'est
extrêmement malin pour venir activer
cette option vous venez dans les
paramètres de votre appareil photo vous
cliquez sur la petite rou cranté ici
vous venez ici dans analyser les docs et
le texte que vous venez activver bien
évidemment et vous allez sur Suppression
des objets indésirables supprimera votre
main un bout de doigt ce que vous voulez
bref c'est quand même vachement cool et
vous pouvez venir activer aussi balayage
automatique qui va venir reconnaître
automatiquement un document et qui
viendra le scanner automatiquement si
vous tenez un document vous avez les
deux mains prises là ça y va plus vite
c'est intuitif et c'est vachement simple
autre nouveauté qui est vachement bien
ici au niveau de oneu IIS c'est le fait
de PIR venir shooter des photos plus ou
moins rapidement par exemple ici je vais
venir prendre en photo mon galaxy S23
ultra il y a toujours un petit moment
entre le moment où j'appuie et moment où
ça déclenche pourquoi et bien parce
qu'il vient traiter la photo pour vous
la maximiser d'un point de vue logiciel
si vous souhaitez venir shooter vous
comme un fou et vous mettre presque en
mode rafale et bien c'est possible ce
qu'il faut faire c'est venir ici dans
les options au niveau de la rou cranté
vous allez au niveau des options
intelligentes avancer en venant laisser
le mode maximum activer et bien il va
venir travailler derrière pour maximiser
la qualité de votre photo tandis que si
vous voulez pas vous prendre la tête
vous voulez que ça aille vite et choter
en mode rafale vous allez sur minimum
vous vous mettez ensuite en mode
appareil photo et là vous appuyez tant
que vous voulez ça shoot ça shoot ça
shoot ça shoot il y a absolument aucun
problème entre nouveauté au niveau du
filigrane je pense qu'on est pas très
nombreux à venir mettre des filigran ou
des watermark directement sur ces photos
mais il y a une petite nouveauté petite
nuance qui étaé faite ici sur oneui 6
par rapport à oneui 5 qui est assez
intéressante je vous montre si par
exemple vous voulez venir prendre une
photo je veux venir faire une photo
directement ici mais surtout je veux
pouvoir dire quel moment j'ai pris cette
photo et bien je vais mettre mon
filigran et dans mes options de filigran
et bien regardez je peux modifier obligé
de mettre le nom du téléphone je peux
mettre monsieur Greux mettre un crédit
en fait sur mon image j'enregistre j'ai
accès surtout ici à la date et à l'heure
donc je ressors des options je fais ma
photo et vous voyez que je trouve mon
fil graine ici Monsieur Greux la date et
l'heure si jeux venir supprimer que
l'heure et bien je peux le faire très
facilement je vais dans les options du
filgan et je décoche l'heure je peux
mettre que la date si je veux ou je peux
mettre que l'heure je fais ce que je
veux ça c'est une option qui n'existait
pas sur oneu 5 vous pouviez uniquement
personnaliser le nom et la date et
l'heure on pouvait pas détacher la date
de l'heure et autre option qui est assez
maline une fois que vous avez fait votre
photo vous dites en fait je veux pas ici
avoir le filigran et bien vous venez sur
les trois petits points en haut et vous
cliquez sur Rétablir l'original et là le
filigran s'en va autre nouveauté
vachement bien c'est un widget qui a
fait son apparition ici avec oneui 6
vous venez pour ajouter un widget vous
cliquez sur widget là vous allez
retrouver le widget appareil photo qui
n'existe pas de l'autre côté bon déjà le
titre de mon widget je m'en fous un
petit peu quoi que vous allez voir mais
surtout le mode de démarrage je peux
choisir soit ma caméra arrière soit ma
caméra avant mais surtout le mode de
photo que ça va venir déclencher la
photo du portrait de la vidéo pro vidéo
pro bref vous avez tous les modes qui
sont là si par exemple vous voulez faire
un mode spécial pour le mode single take
qu'on va prendre uniquement avec la
caméra avant et bien c'est possible ce
qui fait que vous allez venir
personnaliser le titre de votre widget
que vous appellerez single tech selfie
vous choisissez ensuite où est-ce que
vous voulez le mettre dans quel
répertoire et dans quel album très
facile vous pouvez même venir
personnaliser ici l'image de
l'arrière-plan avec une photo prise
depuis un album vous pouvez ensuite
sélectionner une image bon par exemple
celle-là on s'en fout mais c'est juste
pour illustrer et ensuite vous
enregistrer si bien que votre widget
vous servira pour venir shooter en
single take mais surtout sur la caméra
de selfie j'appuie là je suis sur la
caméra de selfie je suis sur single take
et ça c'est quand même extrêmement malin
et je peux en créer autant que je veux
si par exemple je créer plein de
raccourcis pour plein de modes
différents et bien je peux je vais en
faire un par exemple sur la caméra
arrière et ici pour de la vidéo bien là
vous retrouvez avec un deuxième widget
pour venir shooter en vidéo sur la
caméra arrière et si vous souhaitez en
mettre plein à l'arrière pour avoir
plein de raccourcis vous pouvez vous
pouvez venir hop là les rétrécir très
facilement comme ça libre à vous de vous
faire une page avec tous vos modes
photos préférés directement au bout du
doigt c'est rapide c'est simple c'est
intuitif et ça c'est vachement bien
autre nouveauté au niveau des paramètres
la batterie a enfin son paramètres
propres qu'elle avait pas avant bien
vous recherchiez la batterie il fallait
arriver dans batterie et maintenance de
l'appareil c'est bien mais pas terrible
tandis que maintenant si vous regardez
et bien vous avez directement un mode
batterie qui a fait son apparition juste
en dessous d'écran o vous allez
retrouver tous les paramètres de votre
batterie activer l'économie d'énergie
oui non la protection de la batterie oui
non tout votre reporting tout est là
surtout quand on sait que l'autonomie
c'est un point extrêmement important ça
me paraissait normal d'avoir un menu
dédié à la batterie dans les paramètres
ça arrive enfin avec one6 il était en
Samsung est-ce que vous connaissez Bixby
texc qui vous permet de répondre à un
appel téléphonique directement puis
votre smartphone alors je vous montre si
vous connaissez pas c'est très simple là
je suis en train d'appeler et je vais
répondre avec Bixby text call en fait
lorsque vous répondez Bixby va répondre
à votre place si vous pouvez pas parler
mais vous voulez quand même prendre un
appel donc voyez là vous parlez et ça va
le convertir en message directement ça
vous marque tout peu ou prou plutôt bien
et après vous pouvez taper votre message
vous directement l'envoyer et vous
pouvez mettre par exemple un petit ah ok
ah ok je suis occupé je vous rappelle
plus tard et vous pouvez ensuite venir
reprendre votre appel vous directement
vous appuyez là vous passez en appel
vocal et vous vous parlez la grosse
nouveauté est ce qui est intéressant ici
grâce à oneui 6 vous pouvez switcher sur
le bixb Tex call même en appel
téléphonique ça c'était pas possible
avec oneui 5 maintenant on peut le faire
hop et vous repassez directement comme
ça c'est extrêmement pratique bref ici
Samsung rajoute cette nouvelle
fonctionnalité de Bixby textc afin de
vous permettre lorsque vous êtes dans
une conversation de switcher en message
c'est pratique c'est bien pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires autre
nouveauté non des moindes dans votre
application galerie sur galerie la
nouveauté va situer au niveau du bouton
info que vous allez retrouver juste en
bas et ce bouton il va venir combiner
plus plusieurs fonctionnalités au même
endroit sur oneu 5 vous pouviez déjà par
exemple et bien venir modifier l'effet
de l'arrière-plan ça vous le marquez
directement ici vous cliquez dessus et
vous avez accès directement à vos
différents paramètres de flou si vous
voulez remasteriser la photo Fall aller
sur les trois petits points ici et aller
sur remasteriser la photo et vous permet
d'améliorer la photo avec un avant après
avant ici après ici voyez bref ces
petites options elles étaient situées à
différents endroits et aujourd'hui sur
oneu 6 Samsung est venu tout regrouper
en un seul et même endroit ici au niveau
de ce petit bouton info intelligent vous
cliquez dessus et là vous allez
retrouver en haut le remasteriser
l'effet de portrait l'effassur d'objet
vous avez de fait tout ici en un seul et
même endroit et c'est quand même
pratique autre nouveauté qui est
vachement bien lorsque vous venez faire
une modification sur une photo par
exemple voyez j'ai celle-ci on va venir
la modifier directement dans ma galerie
là voyez je l'assombe sauf au niveau de
la vignette bref vous venez faire vos
modifications directement au niveau de
votre photo vous la sauvegardez et ce
que vous faites vous cliquez en haut ici
sur les trois petits points et vous
venez copier les modification vous allez
voir où je en venir vous venez ensuite
choisir différentes photos par exemple
celle-là toute celle-ci et bien je viens
cliquer juste en bas bas ici sur plus et
je fais coller les modifications comme
ça ce que j'ai modifié sur la première
photo va se modifier sur toutes les
autres photos et si je veux venir la
modifier ensuite je clique ici et je
fais rétablir l'original et là ça me
supprime directement les modifications
si vous avez une modification que vous
aimez faire directement sur une photo
vous pouvez l' appppliquer sur
énormément d'autres photos directement
et ça aujourd'hui s'est rendu possible
grâce à oneu i 6 ça c'est bien dans
votre galerie il y a une nouveauté aussi
qui est vachement bien et qui est rendu
possible ici grâce à oneu 6 par exemple
je viens me sélectionner là directement
sur les trois petits points juste en ici
je clique dessus et là je fais
enregistrer sous forme d'un autocollant
si bien que lorsque je vais vouloir
venir envoyer un message directement par
exemple sur WhatsApp dans mes message je
viens cliquer ICI sur petite Emoticon je
vais sur les autocollants et là je vais
me retrouver directement en autocollant
bref vous pouvez en mettre plein partout
où vous voulez que ce soit là que soit
sur des stories vous pouvez créer vos
autocollants et les partager très
facilement avec tous vos amis autre
nouveauté qu'on va retrouver au niveau
du panneau d'affichage rapide lorsque je
passe en mode avion et bien j'ai le
Bluetooth et le wifi qui sont désactivés
mais si par exemple je veux garder le
Bluetooth parce qu'effectivement je suis
dans un avion dans un train et que que
je peux garder le Bluetooth et pas le
Wii et bien je viens activer le
bluetooth si bien que la prochaine fois
que je repasserai en mode avion et bien
garderai en mémoire que j'ai voulu le
Bluetooth et si par exemple je mets le
wifi et pas le Bluetooth j'enlève le
mode avion je réactive tout et je
repasse ici directement en mode avion il
sera accé le Wii et pas le Bluetooth
c'est une petite modification qui a été
rajoutée au niveau du mode avion et qui
vous fera gagner quelques petites
secondes il y a aussi une nouvelle
application qui vient de faire son
arrivée ici avec oneu6 c'est
l'application studio et c'est une
application qui vous permettra de faire
du montage vidéo c'est un peu un cap cut
light qu'on vient retrouver ici vous
venez mettre vos plans vous pouvez venir
les éditer les modifier vous allez
ensuite avoir des transitions
directement au milieu voyez on voit
qu'ici Samsung s'adresse au créateur de
contenu ça paraît logique une fois de
plus parce que vu qu'il viennent vendre
ici des Galaxy Z Z Philip 5 s'adresse
beaucoup au créateurs de contenu ça
paraît logique une fois de plus qu'ils
aient leur solution maison pour le
montage de vidéo dernière astuce pour la
route qui concerne le point d'accès
mobile lorsque vous voulez venir vous
partager la connexion de votre
smartphone avec votre ordinateur avec le
smartphone d'un copain Vous pouvez le
faire mais avec un mot de passe à usage
unique vous allez ici dans connexion et
vous descendez et vous allez jusqu'à
point d'accès mobile et modem juste là
et là vous allez voir vous allez avoir
un menu supplémentaire qui va être le
mot de passe à usage unique que vous
n'avez pas de l'autre côté donc vous
venez l'activer vous venez dedans et là
il vient vous générer un mot de passe à
usage unique si bien que lorsque je
désactive et que je le réactive il va me
générer un nouveau mot de passe pour me
connecter directement pour mon point
d'accès mobile il m'est déjà arrivé de
partager ma connexion internet parce que
j'étais à l'étranger pour dépanner
quelqu'un et lorsqu'on voit que la
personne elle passe toute la journée sur
votre connexion et que je sais que ma
connexion elle est limitée au bout d'un
moment ça serait bien que personne elle
se déconnecte donc au lieu de venir moi
modifier mon mot de passe et de
m'embêter et bien hop là je coupe je
remets le hotspot reste si je veux venir
dépanner un are pote mais je vais pas
connecter tout le monde en même temps
c'est pratique c'est sympa c'est rapide
c'est plutôt bien que Samsung l'intégré
ici dans oneui 6 voilà pour ces quelques
nouveautés ici sur oneu 6 d'ailleurs je
vous invite à venir voir cette vidéo qui
va vous présenter plus en détail
différentes astuces pour bien utiliser
son Samsung Galaxy zflip 5 et ça
croyez-moi c'est aussi une are paire de
manche